today's question comes from barry in
california
he visits daveramsey.com to ask i'm 34
years old
okay i'm about to do step one when i
start work next month
i have 60 grand in debt and i was
wondering why dave ramsey says
use the 401k instead of the roth ira
i feel like i would have more control
using a roth and the taxes won't be so
harsh if i need to take out the money
early
so why is the 401k better than the roth
ira
okay all right barry bottom line here's
the deal
first you're going to attack debt clean
that up get it out of your life then
you're going to start to build up an
emergency fund then you're going to get
to investing
i have to say that because people try to
skip steps you don't jack with the
recipe
okay that's that's first and foremost
but why would we tell you the 401k
over the roth ira well it bottom line
boils down to sheer counting
with a 401k you can put up to five 19
dollars with the with the roth ira you
can do up to six thousand
so you can put more away utilizing the
401k
than you can the the roth ira now if
you're age 50 or over
with the 401k you can do another 6 000
catch-up provision
same can be said with a roth ira if
you're 50 or over you can do an extra
thousand so you can do seven
so it just boils down to pure math
you're able to put more money away in
the 401k than you can with the roth ira
plus if you have a match we're talking
free money
so you know it's kind of one of those
things where we say match beats roth
roth beats traditional what we're saying
is is that if you have the opportunity
to invest and you've got to match
the match is free money so that's going
to beat the roth but the roth is going
to be the traditional 401k where you
don't have a match
and this is a matter of order right you
can max out your 401
and still do the rough oh well you can't
you sure can and so it's all a matter of
getting to that 15
right so that's the goal so barry i love
where your head is
again get yourself out of debt get your
emergency fund up then
invest but if you have a 401k with a
match that's the way to go
now if you don't have a match in your
401k you can start with the roth ira
but you're going to go back to the 401k
for the remaining 15
good question